- Tout a commencé le 25 juillet
lorsque Donald Trump appelle
le président de l'Ukraine,
Volodymyr Zelensky, élu en mai
dernier. Pas seulement pour
le féliciter de sa victoire,
comme le président américain
l'avait d'abord admis,
mais aussi pour lui demander
plusieurs fois d'enquêter
sur Hunter Biden,
le fils de Joe Biden.
Trump voudrait ainsi démontrer
un conflit d'intérêt chez
les Biden qui pourrait
lui servir dans l'éventuelle
campagne présidentielle.
Il faut remonter en 2016
quand Joe Biden, alors
vice-président, s'occupe
du dossier ukrainien au sein
de l'administration Obama.
À l'époque, il demande que soit
congédié le procureur général
d'Ukraine, Viktor Shokin,
qui est accusé de corruption.
Et pour ce faire, il menace
de retenir une garantie de prêt
d'un milliard promise par
les États-Unis à l'Ukraine.
Face à la pression
anticorruption du peuple
ukrainien et de la pression
internationale, Shokin est
finalement limogé.
Fin de l'histoire?
Il faut savoir qu'en 2014,
Hunter Biden, le fils, siègeait
au conseil d'administration
d'une société gazière
ukrainienne, Burisma, qui était
justement au centre d'une
enquête ouverte par Shokin.
Coïncidence?
Trois ans plus tard, Joe Biden
nie qu'il était au courant du
dossier de son fils en Ukraine.
Et jusqu'ici, rien ne prouve
le contraire et n'a démontré
un quelconque conflit d'intérêt.
Mais pour Donald Trump,
ce simple lien familial est
suspect, d'où ses demandes
répétées au nouveau président
ukrainien pour tenter
de mêler son rival démocrate
à de la corruption.
Et depuis plusieurs jours,
tant son avocat Rudy Giuliani...
... que Trump lui-même...
... continuent d'alimenter
les soupçons sur le candidat
favori à l'investiture
démocrate. Mais cette stratégie
se retourne maintenant
contre lui. Surtout depuis
qu'un lanceur d'alerte a déposé,
le 12 août dernier, une plainte
formelle contre le président
américain pour ses demandes
répétées à une puissance
étrangère d'enquêter sur
un rival politique américain.
La pression de Trump aurait
même été assortie d'une menace
de retrait d'une aide
de 250 millions de dollars
à l'Ukraine.
La plainte aurait dû être
transmise au Congrès sept jours
plus tard. Or, le directeur
du renseignement national par
intérim a refusé de le faire.
Pour les démocrates, les actes
de Donald Trump dans ce dossier
représentent, en tout cas,
un motif sérieux de destitution.
Ici Frédéric Arnould, Radio-Canada, Montréal.